Winchester Mystery House في سان خوسيه
كاليفورنيا هي واحدة من أكثر
الأماكن المسكونة في أمريكا. Winchester Mystery
House هو قصر فيكتوري فريد بشكل لا يصدق
تم إنشاؤه بواسطة سارة وينشستر
وريثة ثروة Winchester Repeating Arms ،
تعرضت سارة وينشستر لسلسلة من
الأشياء المؤسفة التي حدثت لها
بما في ذلك الوفاة  من زوجها
وابنتها كانت روحانية
وزارت وسيطًا لمحاولة فهم
سبب قول الوسيط جيدًا البندقية ،
هناك الكثير من الكارما في
الغرب ، لذا اتجه غربًا وابني منزلًا لإرضاء
هذه الأرواح التي بدأت
في بنائه في عام 1884  الذي لم يتوقف حتى يوم
وفاتها ، المنزل عبارة عن مائة
وستين غرفة من القصر الفيكتوري ليس
مخططًا رئيسيًا ، هناك الكثير من السمات الغريبة ،
هناك 40 سلمًا ، 40
مدفأة ، أربعة مصاعد ، لدينا
عدد من السلالم التي تؤدي إلى
أبواب السقف مباشرة  التي تنفتح على
لا شيء أو أنها مجرد جدار ، يشتهر المنزل
بأرواحه التي يعتقد الكثير من الناس
أنها الأشباح  من الأشخاص الذين
عملوا في المنزل أو حتى سارة
نفسها ، كان الكثير من ضيوفنا
وموظفينا قد حدث لهم أشياء غريبة جدًا ،
هذا المنزل أحيانًا يكون مجرد خطى
أو سماع صوت الحياة التي
تومض أو أحيانًا يكون
مظهرًا جسديًا حقيقيًا كاملًا إذا كنا
لم نحل الألغاز منذ 93 عامًا ،
فأنا لا أعرف ما إذا كنا من قبل
[موسيقى]